hey guys welcome to the Reuben report
i'm dave rubin we have a great show for
you Gina grad Vanessa Barnett with us
and let's get right to it Hillary
Clinton she was interviewed by those fun
people over at Fox News Fox News scary
right she sat in between Greta Van
Susteren on one side bret baier on the
other she got pretty severe whiplash
from the questioning of course literally
half of it was about Benghazi have you
heard there's some kind of situation the
Republicans are all going crazy about
let's take a look my own assessment
careened from you know the video had
something to do with that the video had
nothing to do with it it may have
affected some people it didn't affect
other people and I think the the
conclusion to draw because we were not
just monitoring what was happening in
Benghazi once it began to unfold but
remember we had a very dangerous assault
on our embassy in Cairo that same day
which was clearly linked to that video
so I was trying to make sense of it and
you know i think that the investigations
that have been carried out basically
conclude we can't say that everybody was
influenced and we can't say everybody
wasn't but what the intelligence
community said was spontaneous protests
and that is what at the time they
thought okay so actually she did what a
lot of politicians you shouldn't really
say anything we sort of knew we kind of
didn't know a we did the best we could
but i actually pretty much think that's
the truth i don't think they
intentionally tried to get these people
killed i tend to think they probably did
the best they could to secure our
embassy in our people there uh so
without getting into the nitty-gritty of
benghazi which no one seems to know the
truth about when they do questions like
this on fox news uh what's the goal is
the goal to just keep hitting the base
is the goal to change any did like does
she think she's changing anyone's mind
with an answer like that does Fox think
they're changing I just wanted like the
bigger sort of media question about it
well first can I just say the girl looks
good in royal blue Rico great choice for
her that's her way of saying I'm a real
Democrat Hillary jewel tones yeah read
by the way thank you
yeah thank you um I think I think that's
a fair question because when you're
invited onto a show present company
excluded I think the point is to either
you know paint you into a corner make
you look stupid or get you to say
something completely outrageous that
you'd never want to say and I think her
whole job which I think she did a great
job that was just taking the fuel out of
the fire quelling if she did a little
double-talk and was super vague I think
she did what she was supposed to do
right so is that their purpose they
bring her on there they know she's not
going to say anything and that's pretty
much what she did we sort of knew we
didn't know blah blah blah but it's a
fair question and they're going to ask
it and they they want to kind of poke
the bear a little bit and they want a
reaction i think they honestly do want
something that they can you know put on
a headline and say oh look at Hilary she
did this and they might even try to
spend something that she did say but
like he said she played it safe and it
was vague but I think a lot of times in
politics you have to keep it vague
because when you say something and you
kind of have to go back on that oh my
god the walls come crashing down on you
imagine having to tell the truth and say
what you actually believe people would
people would freak out this isn't just
some random woman I mean this is
somebody who's going to be running for
president presumably this somebody who's
been obviously super connected to the
obama white house because she works for
him so what do they expect her to say
right so so that's the thing do you
think this is more about them attacking
obama or attacking her is this their
preemption on 2016 like we got to keep
this thing going we know Obama's it out
no matter what so forget him let's just
keep the pressure on her why not double
down I mean if they it doesn't matter
it's either if they're trying to get get
Obama presently or get her for the
future they win either way yeah all
right so mo I mean it's Fox News I don't
think anyone surprised it's kind of like
their mo that's what they did so
speaking of their mo so let's get away
from Benghazi I think that's the
interesting thing here is that everyone
was framing this as Hillary's going a
fox news it's so scary but in a weird
way isn't that a condemnation in that's
no defense of fox news but isn't that a
condemnation of the rest of our media
because the implication is well the rest
of the media loves her they give her
softball questions all the time but now
she's going up odds and it's really
scary and actually if you watch the
interview
Oh thing wasn't that scary there was
nothing particularly uh you know pointed
yeah it was pretty tame so isn't it a
bigger condemnation of the media that we
said we have one outlet that's supposed
to be the scary one for Democrat I think
just historically they have been the
[ __ ] of TV I mean that's what they
know they've kind of set themselves up
that way so that now we are just so
accustomed to say old Fox News Sox's but
like you said we watch it it's pretty
tame but we're still gonna be like oh
here she's going to fox news it's just
the history of what they've done yeah
they dug that hole for themselves so
it's not like we're all pouncing on them
for no reason right if you want to be
sensational it's be sensationalist but
don't be mad when people assume that's
what you're gonna do again and I will
say I don't think the rest of the media
gives our softball questions I think
they ask the pertinent questions but
they're not coming from a vicious
malicious angle and I think in the past
maybe not with this interview but in
past that's what Fox News does yeah so
we've done a bunch of stories on her and
I absolutely can't support her I just
don't think we need political dynasties
her husband was president I think no one
in my family's been president I think if
you someone in your family's been
presidents are you don't get to be
President like that I know that's crazy
wind concert tickets if your family
works for the radio there are about
nepotism here you love it yeah my
daddy's Barack did me at all yeah what
is your dad you my dad sees look at you
not great now really really show
okay so so I'm just completely against
here because I just I just think we need
fresh new people this is just gonna be
more of the same you George Bush had his
son do it like I just don't think 40
people are saying that Michelle Obama
might run for Senate inch in Illinois
like it's just endless it's endless um
violence oh my quite platform yeah
exactly just to get everybody fit yeah
um so my final question is as women
because you are women's must represent
all women that's how it works women do
you are you more inclined to vote for
her I'm gonna be honest yes yeah and I
didn't vote for obama just because he
was black but hey I'm not gonna lie that
was a part of it is like you want that
as an african-american want me you want
that as a woman I want to see her in the
White House and I know what we say about
you know the same old rigmarole but you
also want someone you can trust and so
because she's been in it and because i
loved clinton as a president I'm more
inclined to say okay she's a woman she
understands that and she knows the game
she knows these people and so I just
trust her a little bit more I don't want
some guy I've never heard of before
coming in like oh I'll save the day I
just don't think that's what I hear you
and in a weird way I would be more
inclined to vote for bill again so I
guess maybe I take a little bet away
from what I said before but what do you
think is it would it push you a little
bit honestly I I don't know why like if
I'm saying this because I'm exhausted
and got four hours of sleep because of a
cat situation that I was dealing with or
because I really believe I don't know
but at this moment I really feel like
that stuff can't matter it can't matter
if she's a woman it can't matter it it
just can't yeah so I I'm not I don't
want to just completely counter out like
this grow because you know she would be
part of this dynasty and I can't say
well it doesn't matter what she stands
for I want to support her because she's
women I just I maybe there's a part of
me that does feel that way i don't know
i don't think so though I just I can't
have those be the reasons yeah all right
Iraq is a total freaking mess you
probably have heard about that so right
now Isis which is the Islamic state in
Iraq and Syria or ISIL as President
Obama is calling it the Islamic state in
Iraq and the
that is basically marching through Iraq
they've split the country pretty much
into three territories all based on uh
you know sectarian stuff and the Sunni
and the Shia and all that stuff okay I
want to get to too deep into it cuz
we're not policy wonks here uh but
President Obama said that he wasn't
gonna send any troops we've now said 275
troops to secure our embassy which
people don't know the embassy in Baghdad
is the biggest US Embassy in the world
there are five thousand US citizens that
work there uh there may be limited drone
strikes it's all sort of on unfolding
very quickly so again we are not experts
in security but that's why I'm doing the
show to have sort of normal people talk
about the broader issues um what should
we do solve it for us right now that was
a big one no pressure oh I was just
gonna say bring in archer if any of your
Archer fans blow that Isis figure that's
an Isis reference yeah I I don't I I
don't know I don't know what to do and I
it doesn't matter if you're listening to
am talk FF talk everybody's talking
about this and nobody knows what to do
so if they don't know and they get paid
to figure it out i sure's yeah we are
you saying that we shouldn't be
listening to the same people the
architects of the original Iraq war
right now cuz all those guys they're all
showing up all over the place yeah this
is the time shine let me do I make it
work this time why is it that when they
put these people back on the cable news
channels they don't put under their
names [ __ ] up the first yeah yeah
really [ __ ] Bill Kristol to expert no
expert exactly yeah so really what what
do you think we should do I mean look
it's a freaky this is a disaster this
could cause this could cause Jordan to
fall also I mean this is just the
beginning 275 troops obviously maybe can
defend our embassy but can't defend a
country and does it even matter should
we just let them all kill each other do
yeah exactly do we is that our role to
take care of that I don't think so i
don't know i was trying to read through
all the facts and i can't ingest it oh
it's just so heavy but i do agree that
we need the troops there to protect our
people and that's why i was saying
before that's apologist you want to stay
babe because he said no troops and then
he had to send some in and is like hey
going back on your word but at the end
of the day I think their goal is the
goal that we should all be worried about
protecting our people that are there
everything else I just kind of want to
stay out of it's just it'll only come
back on us and then we're in another war
so I basically agree with you like
there's nothing we can do these people
have hated each other forever this is
goes beyond us but we did throw a bomb
literally when we went to war there so
should we do what you feel are we guilty
you don't even shoot our guilty
conscience lead us back into cleaning up
anything as if we even if it was
remotely possible that we could or do we
just say that the whole place now that
we can do sorry we screwed it up sorry
and that's the thing I mean I don't mean
to oversimplify it but that's exactly
what I'm gonna do I mean it's lonely at
the top you know when when we do go in
we're bullies when we don't go in or
heartless yeah so I don't know why what
makes this situation different than
every other situation that we've been
struggling with grief do we try to fix
it or do we stay out of it because
either way we're gonna be in trouble
yeah what do you make of it go ahead as
I say and make it worse yeah who says
we're gonna fix it like if even if we'd
send everyone in there's no guarantee
that we'll fix it it's probably gonna
into far worse yeah what do you guys
make the general theme in the country
would see which seems to be that we
should be pulling back from the rest of
the world you know to me like that
everything happened in Ukraine we're not
even talking about you going anymore
we've sort of lost in terms of what we
said we was supposed to happen I mean
Russia pretty much one okay what do you
think of this the general feeling in the
United States like that we sort of don't
have a role anymore which is sort of
what Obama promised he said we're gonna
step back and that's what happen you
want our promise don't ya we want the
promise even if there's a lot of bad
should happen right I think you just get
to a point where you're fed up and like
just like we're talking right now we're
overwhelmed we don't think we can fix
anything why why put ourselves in a
position to make it far worse for them
and for us it's like let's just wash our
hands step away and we shift our focus
because there's things here we need to
work on yeah and I don't think we want
to use our resources for outside outside
problems right is there anyone that you
watch on TV on any of the news channels
that you really trust when it comes to
this is there any politician that when
they come on you feel like they really
know what they're talking about or
have you seen scandal they're all lines
I haven't seen scalar but i watch i
watch me penthouse a card that gives me
a pretty good sense what's going to it
they're all right i mean is there anyone
that you watch then you're like this guy
really has ironically joe biden when he
was running for president in 2008 before
he joined obama he was the one saying
that there's this country needs to be
split into three things bay which is
crazy because everyone thinks the guys
completely nuts now but Uncle Jim crazy
crazy uncle joe and he was making this
point way back then but really is there
anyone that you know babies i say i do
then i end up looking like an idiot
because it's because they they they're
so relatable or they're so charming and
they're just they're folksy and i like
that but it doesn't end up mattering I
don't know what they know they only know
what they want me to know so I always
end up feeling stupid anyway I am great
your lack of all right from Iraq let's
move back here to America although this
is a worldwide company to if i'm not
mistaken mcdonald's people are not happy
with them and their score on the
American Customer Service index is
falling let's take a look so this is a
favor ability score for pretty big chain
restaurants fast food restaurants we do
a bunch of fast food stuff here people
people are always very passionate about
it so Papa John's doing pretty well they
got a 82 out of 100 which is uh they
didn't move from last year people like
them in 2013 they like them in 2014
Pizza Hut number too so people seem to
really like generic chain pizza does
that where do you guys fall on that I'm
from the Midwest I didn't know there was
anything more exotic than a pizza hut
but Gaddy looked away from there I don't
know how you can stop right so this is
like New York obviously not going to go
to pizza hut or dominos or Papa John's
yeah got real peach pies all right let's
let's go back to cart there and again
then then little caesars and Domino's
Pizza so the first four people are very
satisfied with shitty pizza uh but then
ok so then on the bottom the last four
Burger King Dunkin Donuts KFC talk about
McConnell guy gave you five there so
McDonald's really kind of struggling and
I was when I was watching something you
know people have said that their numbers
their their take-home right now is
dropping a little bit but is this partly
just people like to beat up
on the thing that they secretly love
like everyone talks [ __ ] about walmart
and everyone shops there you know
although i actually i went there to get
a big screen TV and the customer service
was so bad i actually brought the TV up
carry the TV myself brought it to the
register and he was taking so long and
they were being so unpleasant i just
left it there like jerry seinfeld you
returned the sports coat o spite i didn
t really respect ya but really do you
think that's some of what's going on
here like McDonald's hasn't changed that
much there's no reason you know oh yeah
go ahead all the lies it was all the
lies in the world I tell people I hate
mcdonalds because that's what you're
supposed to say woman I love it oh wow
and then you go and you buy the entire
dollar menu and you sit in your room in
your life yes McDonald you can't say
that you liked it because it's just in
this day and age what everyone wants to
be organic and natural and gluten-free
and XY and z you can't say you like me
how do you feel after you've done that
in your room just pour it all that dog
and freakin task yeah thank you yeah I
got a shame spiral haha shame spiral
here too we should all go out for
McDowell's maybe you could teach us to
quickly i Doan it what do you is this
like secret hate like ya ba hima guys I
know I absolutely disagree for one
reason yeah because I don't know if it
was two days ago or yesterday the the
abominable horrible thing that happened
to that little girl at KFC when she was
mauled by a dog and she was scarred and
the family took her into KFC and they
asked her to leave a little girl because
she was making the other customers
uncomfortable if that's what customer
services at fast food [ __ ] all of them
yeah and that is what a lot of customer
services they're not all the course
serve to fall vitally i'm pretty sure
KFC has now helped her pace a medical
bills or something and so I understand
that corporate wasn't there and this is
just some dude tryna whatever I can't
cover up to the thirty thousand dollar
for medical bills or millions in a
lawsuit but I don't you know blame the
founder of get on right late the kernel
for this whole thing but I i do
understand you know they probably
wouldn't have wanted their employee to
treat another person like that but if
that's the culture your breeding then I
don't feel sorry for you right and there
is a lot of that because here even in LA
now that I want to make
but if you were to go to an in and out
it may smile they're friendly I mean
they make a point of service yeah in the
eye they are happy to be there
McDonald's they don't give a flying [ __ ]
about you and I get it they're paying
different things and there's different
business model lot but I'm glad you
brought up KFC because the other two so
at the bottom we're KFC and Taco Bell
Taco Bell I think has the reverse thing
of me isn't it cool to like taco bell if
you it adds further you know they got
the Doritos the kids love it there's
extra taco bell plays yes that
commercial with the old people never
learn kids love it Young so I think they
get the reverse things somehow it's cool
to say that you like Taco Bell not cool
to say you like me down Sam I am I think
taco bell completely is the same thing
as the movie idiocracy they mirror each
other you can take the same nine
ingredients and shuffle the deck in a
different way and get a whole new
product and get people excited they're
geniuses we're morons but they're
geniuses by the way in the movie
idiocracy which is such an underrated
movie that's really so spectacular the
one fast food restaurant that survives
the future is Carl's jr. which didn't
which is horrible which is horrible now
and didn't even make chick-fil-a can we
talk about why should filets not on the
list they have the best customer there
they're always like the hot pleasure
yeah what about the gay thing what about
the gay thing Oh chicken but I loved
what people too oh my love Reggie you
know what we had a Cara Santa Maria on a
couple weeks ago and she made the same
argument i love them right here again
that i love gay people like what you
know you can't win you can't win oh is
in life anyway the point is McDonald's
it's just not that great and you'd
probably be happier elsewhere okay let's
talk about another chain though let's
talk about starbucks because they're
actually doing something that's pretty
cool they've announced that they're
going to be paying for tuition for two
years of online classes at Arizona State
University for some of their employees
we've got some more info about seventy
percent of starbucks 135,000 us
employees have not completed
undergraduate degrees employees can now
choose any of more than 40 undergraduate
degrees and aren't limited to only
business class
so you can do whatever you want which is
cool because a lot of people working at
Starbucks are doing it so that they
could become artists or whatever they
whatever they want to be employees
aren't required to stay with the company
after receiving their degrees and
tuition is approximately 30,000 for two
years I mean this is real this is a real
investment that they're making with
their employees understanding that these
people are not always going to be with
them and they're going to go fulfill
their own dreams pretty great right I
think it's awesome I'm gonna get a job
at starbucks no but it's fantastic
because a lot of times you're getting
these shots and they just want to hold
you there they don't want you to grow
they want you to stay in your position
so they can make money off of you this
is like the complete reverse they're
giving you money and giving you wings so
you can fly and do something else yeah
thanks great so isn't that the real
beauty of this whole operation and it's
totally counterintuitive to a business
model to get you to a place where you
don't have to work at that company
anymore and I'm suspicious I just feel
like we're conspiracy I don't I don't
know what I don't even know what I'm
suspicious up but I know I'm suspicious
because this is it seems too good to be
true they don't care what you major in
they'll pay for it they don't care if
you start if you work at Starbucks
continue online classes and quit they
don't really care as long as you're
working what 20 hours a week it's too
good I'm afraid there's gonna be a catch
well how much does this kind of stuff
make you want to go to Starbucks so when
you hear that they give all their
employees health insurance you know
before Obamacare or whatever did that
affect even if their coffee isn't the
greatest I actually think is pretty good
but yes really I don't even care if they
burn their beans I'm so excited that
they're doing this I think this is
really I mean truly people at thrown the
American history you join the military
to get a benefit like this yeah and this
is just you know make a couple double
lattes god bless all those dealing with
people in the morning before they've had
their coffee can be quite like a worm
you know it can be sure sure I just
think this is so phenomenal I just hope
that we're all not being duped because
it's so good and it's it's just so good
of them yeah how much of this comes do
you think from like just the business
perspective of just people talking about
it like we're talking about and they get
that good that good will versus like
sort of a real genuine caring for their
employees it may not matter which
actually I think we all container
corporations that a person
right we also plane about a five dollar
latte but if you're not telling me Oh a
dollar of your five dollars goes to help
young Megan here achieve her goals of
being a neuroscientist come PS yeah I
feel better about my coffee can you
become a neuroscientist online at
Arizona State University no Megan what
she can't Megan Megan Zager I don't make
this about negative maybe she's a great
girl as Megan have you heard the new
term spore no sexual yes porno sexuals
are the new metrosexuals uh Mark Simpson
who's the journalist who coined the term
metrosexual and these were these guys
had started probably about 10 years ago
who cared what they look like they wore
clothes that were a little tighter kind
of a little gayer but they weren't gay
they were straight guys it seemed to
look a little gayer put your pillow more
product in their hair that kind of thing
I kept feeling good about my hair to
look great uh-uh but now she's now
talking about spore no sexuals and this
is this new group of men who are who are
hyper sexual and body obsessed uh we've
got an explanation of the spore no
sexual with their painstakingly pumped
and chiseled body's muscle enhancing
tattoos piercings adorable beards and
plunging necklines it's eye-catching Lee
clear that the second generation
metrosexuality is less about clothes
than it was for the first their own
bodies more than clobber and product
have become their ultimate accessories
fashioning them at the gym into a hot
commodity one that they share and
compare in an online marketplace so the
online marketplace that he's talking
about of course is social media that
people are taking the you know selfies
everywhere at the gym perfect bodies
tattooed can tight haircuts blah blah
blah um is this is the gay agenda is it
working are they turning all of the
straight people gay is that what
happening here yes and you know when I
bring the children the Charlie this is
fantastic I mean I think that first of
all it's a great definition terrible
name it sounds like you have some sort
of a spore induced STD yeah but god
bless Sporto sexual the first thing I
thought I mean you know my golden good
thing
Dorothy Zbornak so I thought it was
someone that was obsessed with Bea
Arthur perhaps which is what I do which
is I could be that considered I can't
live in a world that wonderful there is
no utopia work everywhere a sport or
sexual everyone obsessed with the Arthur
but I mean this is absolutely accurate
is it not I mean hit the word hipster is
so played out and I don't even think
that that definition really means
anything anymore I think it's the spore
no sexual you got the beard you got the
plunging neckline yeah and you have all
your glamour muscles exactly where you
want them you probably can't actually
lift something heavy but you look great
right so this is accurate right right
well this reminds me of i live in West
Hollywood and all these guys that have
huge muscles and they probably couldn't
throw a ball four feet away because it's
all about the visual component do you do
you like these kind of guys I love it
this is just an excuse to not wear
clothes anymore no one wants to wear
clothes like you have james franco just
holding this junk and I see your pubes
on Instagram i saw something of the day
we're now you know your little speedo
used to wear a speedo now it's like 15
completo it's just like a ball it's like
fat yeah just goes over once lot like
people just no one we're close cuz I
want to show off their abs and their
arms and their nipples in there whatever
i love it i think it's hilarious I
didn't think I'm Dean that could go down
to your ankle right like what is it now
she's like a robe like what is it I love
it yeah do you think there's some
element of it that men lose a little
something something that women love
about men maybe when they're so into
themselves you know men are always
complaining every sitcom ever is about
the man complaining the white it's
caring about too much your hair and
herbal and now men are doing it yeah and
then the other complaint is well I don't
want to date a guy that takes longer to
get ready than I do right and I mean
that for me that's impossible because I
mean clearly this took no more than 50 I
find what that that's that's not how
uncomfortable but I think that I think
they're that you're both right I think
it's fun I candy it's fun to look at
it's fun to make fun of it's fun to talk
about it's fun to see pictures of but in
general do I feel like I'm gonna connect
to somebody who is just like all oiled
up probably not my guy but i love the
conversation yeah what do you think
what's the phase after this if it
started you had regular guys then you
the metrosexuals now we got this porno
sex I mean it's just everyone's
important next is that where we're going
is that it does that over my thirty
thousand dollars are both astonishing to
battle gave us rolled into the this this
for no way that's right no I think what
it does is just breeds more narcissism
and the Instagram the selfie the I see
that everything is the e it just breathe
I just it's all about me and me and me
and look at my house it's just over the
top it's over the top yeah a new study
out of Japan is saying that people who
stare at screens all day long laptop
screens as specifically phone screens
they are actually changing the liquid in
their eyes this is really deranged
they're changing tear fluid similar to
people who have a disease known as dry
eye let's look at some info on the study
the protein muc5ac one of my favorite
proteins secreted by cells in the upper
eyelid makes up part of the normally
occurring mucus layer or tear film that
keeps the I moist we all have this
that's why you can blink and it keeps
bad dust and things out of your eyes
study participants with the most screen
time had muc5ac levels nearing those of
people with diagnosed dry eye so when I
was reading this literally I had just
woke up and do you guys go to your
phone's right when you wake up because I
do it it's a bad habit I've been trying
to break it and I looked at my phone and
there are times especially first thing
in the morning I wake up and my eyes are
dry and I'm literally I got one eye and
I lower the light on yet and I'm going
like this like what is that so this is
happening this is real what do you think
about how do you keep your eyes moist
well I know the first thing I thought
there's gonna be so many people that are
going this is stupid this is BS it's not
true shut up but those are people who
don't want to accept that the things
that they're doing are bad for them yeah
so it's I think it's it's probably true
I'm willing to go for it and maybe put
my phone down for another half hour
before I wake up do you have that do you
do you have any moments where you
realize that your eyes are bothering you
because of the screen or the new thing
now is everyone's making their screens
darker at night there's
it'll actually do that young but another
thing we know this is real because
wasn't there a guy in China recently
that detached his retinas he was texting
all night with his girlfriend literally
yes our heads are gonna pop off next I
mean seriously like this is insane we're
roading our tear ducts where our
eyeballs are popping out of our skulls I
mean maybe we put the phone down for
five minutes yeah I mean are you doing
this are you walking around with your
phone because they're saying also neck
things daily I I've walked into two
glass like literally just textin away
and bam just done it but when I read
this I it sounds a little insensitive
but I'm like dry i like diagnose dry I
there's so many other things that are so
much worse than live like try you're
gonna get it you're gonna get a lot of
hate from the dryer community which
they're a big bright green fire that
wasn't a big deal and so I just I kind
of laugh I was like it felt like a duh
study like of course if you're staring
at a computer screen or your telephone
or anything in excess is gonna be bad
for you I just don't care that much
about dry eyes yes sorry the girl with
lv eyes right now who's walking into
glad wait till the day your walk right
to do a glass thing in your phone goes
right in your eyes okay then okay then
you look at is there anything we can do
to fight this stuff because because we
all do it we all do it there is no doubt
you know you mean and i said it about
the wake up thing I've been trying to
shut down I tried by nine o'clock now
I've really been trying I'm not always
successful to stop looking at Twitter so
I'm doing you know my little I'm all you
know I barely open i'm doing Instagram
every third day now every day like I'm
just trying to to slowly do it um but do
you try to fight it in any way I just
ever encroaching but I like I'm gonna
speak for Vanessa when she's gonna be
like visine and stop crying but I think
this is I think this is really good
information and they're not even saying
like oh god everybody panic they're like
just so you know so you don't care Doc's
are being totally ravaged but do do you
yeah what about you are you doing
anything to fight it or because you
admit it you freely admit it yeah I I'm
more so the type persons like okay when
I'm at home it's family time let's put
away our phones it's dinnertime let's
put away
fun but not because I'm scared of dry
eye as well connect with people I don't
want to always be you know doing it for
the likes I just want to like get back
to dinner time where you talk to your
family yeah I look what you say dry I
can you say that he's dry it was such a
venom dry I I all right well I hope you
guys have enjoyed watching this and that
your eyes are fully lubricated and move
around your head and all that good stuff
Gina Vanessa thank you guys their
twitters are right down below of course
subscribe like keep watching don't
listen to that segment that was not for
you guys that was just for the general
public was a you know public service
thing and we will see you next week